للمرة الأولى
، اقترح الرئيس دونالد ترامب علنًا أنه قد
يركز على إمكانية طرد الدكتور أنتوني
أنتوني فوسي ، كبير خبراء الأمراض المعدية
في الولايات المتحدة
التي تسمعها بنفسك ، هذا هو
التبادل مع المؤيدين في مسيرة في
فلوريدا منذ فترة قصيرة
[  تصفيق]
لا تخبر أي شخص ولكن دعني أنتظر
قليلاً بعد الانتخابات
[تصفيق]
التي كانت في وقت سابق من هذا المساء ،
لست مضطرًا لأن أخبرك بهذا أنك تعلم أن
الرئيس لديه علاقة خلافية
مع دكتور فوسي وأثناء  الرئيس
يصر على أن الدولة قد تحولت
الزاوية ، قال الطبيب للتو في عطلة نهاية هذا الأسبوع
بأننا نواجه الكثير من
الأذى يأتي مع ارتفاع أسعار Covet 19
في الولايات المتحدة ويحذر الخبراء من أن
الأسوأ لم يأت بعد في
نوفمبر بدأ مع  معظم الحالات
التي تم الإبلاغ عنها على الإطلاق في أحد أيام الأحد ، تشهد أكثر
من 80 ألف
ولاية في الغرب الأوسط على وجه الخصوص
المزيد من حالات العلاج في المستشفيات مع بدء
السباق الرئاسي.